allez on reprend la route avec
christophe et toujours son vtt pour
cette fois une balade dédié au
patrimoine au point de départ le golf
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines et
puis hop on s'échappe directement par
magna les hameaux par le maire hanté par
la maison des bonheurs qui se trouve
derrière moi l'église saint germain des
prés le château de boissy pour finir par
la croix du bois à voisins le bretonneux
caméra gopro sur le casque c'est parti
je vous propose maintenant de une base
pour découvrir donc le patrimoine
historique de magny les hameaux
nous sommes là actuellement sur le golf
national qui accueille au mode juillet
donc l'open de france et qui va
accueillir en 2018 la ryder cup donc la
bague que je vous propose aujourd'hui
est une boucle de 12 km donc une durée
moyenne de une heure et pour les plus
sportifs d'entre vous une trentaine de
minutes devrait suffire
cette balade a peut être sympa à faire à
pied aussi bien sûr on mettra pas le
même temps de parcours
la balade que qu'on propose passe un peu
partout les types de terrain aussi bien
par la route par des chemins escarpés il
ya deux passages assez technique
lorsqu'on rentre dans
au niveau de mes rentes et
une bonne descente
attend les plus sportifs est suivie
d'une belle montée
lorsqu en fait on passe la porte du mes
rentes et donc on aborde une descente
très technique
qui après nous offre plein de
possibilités si
si les partis veulent s'aventurer vers
d'autres parcours
faut savoir que les balades qu'on fait
sont aussi là pour donner l'envié aux
gens de sortir et s'évader
donc là on vient de passer les portes du
mes rentes et on va rentrer dans la
forêt ça va être la partie sympa du
parcours qui me suivait
alors mon coup de coeur ce cette balade
donc c'est juste après la descente du
monte on peut découvrir
un passage avec un ruisseau et en avoir
cette semaine conservé
cette balade qui a pour but de nous
faire découvrir le patrimoine historique
de magny les hameaux nous propose
plusieurs sites à découvrir donc
notamment les portes de mes rentes et la
maison du bonheur ou encore le château
de broussy
à
et parallèlement à ces balades proposées
par l'office de tourisme il ya des
randonnées organisées par l'association
ville verte il dit vous explique tout ça
pour
aller on retrouve maintenant cindy
gaudin chargée de mission à
l'association ville verte bonjour sine
die alors vous pendant tout l'été on
fait en tout cas du 10 juillet au 7 août
vous à nous proposer une balade à partir
d'ici le parc des sources de la bière
les mercredis et samedis parlez nous un
peu de cette balade alors ses ballades
aussi j'ai envie de dire voilà l'idée
est venue de l'office de tourisme et
dans le cadre de l'enrichissement de son
offre de sortie ils ont accédé sortie
sur le thème de l'environnement et du
coup on a convenu d'un agenda qui
permettra aux saint quentinois de
pouvoir découvrir la la nature ordinaire
qui se cachent juste sous leurs portes
juste à côté de chez eux sur les thèmes
un petit peu bancs des arbres des
animaux des oiseaux et on finira même en
permettant aux familles de pouvoir se
transformer en artiste de nature sais
quoi d autre nature alors on leur
permettra voit pas le temps passer en
mode oiseau ou un ordre non non non
l'idée safra pouvoir créer avec est dans
la nature on va l'utiliser la nature
comme support de création de devenir une
palette pour pouvoir permettre aux
enfants comme aux plus grands de pouvoir
s'initier au land art d'accord donc ça
veut dire plutôt réaliser des peintures
ddm mais à partir de matériaux et de
fleurs de bois et des matériaux de la
nature
il faut avoir faim vont être imaginatif
mais même si on n'est pas imaginer si
vous serez guidé
d'accord c'est manager 10 parties si de
ce départ des sources de la bière donc
effectivement il ya un côté un peu
remarquable parce qu'on va vraiment
regarder la nature autrement qu'est ce
qu'il ya de remarquable qu'on pouvoir
avoir avant de commencer l'entretien on
a vu un héron s'envoler baltes et
spectacles vont pas le voir mais est-ce
que ça fait partie des choses un peu
étonnante qu'on peut découvrir à
l'occasion de ces balades oui même si le
héros fait partie de la faune je vais
dire ordinaire ils ont toujours des
petites histoires insolites alors les
ronds mais bien d'autres animaux qui
sont très souvent communs mais ils ont
très souvent des histoires insolites
dont on ne soupçonne pas vraiment
l'existence
on a très souvent des animaux qui sont
plus que banal et qui recèle d'une
grande diversité comme par exemple
observé alors il va voir si on a la
chance il va y avoir tout un tas alors
on va faire des sorties au travers des
de tout ce qui est l'oiseau il ya par
exemple sur les temps il ya des grèves
des grèbes huppés donc c'est un oiseau
assez assez majestueux on pourra
peut-être avoir l'occasion d'observer on
aura peut-être aussi l'occasion de
pouvoir observer à quelques petites
bêtes de la litière qu'on n'a pas
l'habitude de pouvoir voir des mille
pattes des scarabées un petit peu
extraordinaire
à maison tout équipement d'accord c'est
quoi comme équipement à des gens n'ont
pas besoin de venir avec un équipement
leur prête nom du tout là ces choses
qu'on leur conseille c'est quand même de
venir avec une tenue adaptée au climat à
la sortie mon bain des chaussures qui
tiennent un minimum le pied une
casquette de l'eau et de la bonne humeur
d'accord la bonne humeur surtout la
balle a fait combien de temps pas par là
au moins on va parler km mais peut-être
torrontes an plus tôt entend alors
l'idée c'est de se donner rendez vous à
13h45 à l'office de tourisme de saint
quentin pour un départ vers 14 heures
on indique même les gens pouvoir ramener
un petit 4 heures pour qu'on puisse
finir la sortie donc aux alentours de
17h sur un moment convivial et des
changes est ce que c'est une balade
qu'on fait à pied cyniquement et sk des
difficultés particulières pour les gens
qui peuvent avoir des problèmes de
marche c'est vraiment adapté à tout type
de public ils ont écrit des familles y
compris des petits quoi tout à fait puis
on sera vraiment sur un principe de
balade on n'est pas sûr de la randonnée
voilà donc c'est plutôt de l'observation
la sortie découverte ponctuée d'ateliers
d'accord mais ça veut dire qu'on va
s'arrêter sur certains croient tout à
fait ça sera dirait un petit peu aussi
au gré des sentiers nous on aura bien
sûr repéré quelques petites richesse au
préalable on ne manquera pas d'aller
s'arrêter mais voilà si sur notre chemin
des animaux nous ont laissé des traces
etc voilà on ne manquera pas pouvoir
s'arrêter qui va animer ces balades
alors ce qui ce sont des spécialistes
ont des animateurs nature donc moi même
où ma collègue roxane auger qui
travaille également à l'association
alors si vous aviez il ya des secrets la
red bull et nous quand même des petits
secrets des petites histoires d'arbres
un peu remarquable j'ai pas non plus
tout vous dire ah bon mais quand même
mais alors si je fais ou de mettre un
peu l'eau à la bouche par exemple alors
d'un nous on un arbre c'est le sol le
sol au travers d' voilà deux récits
qu'on a retrouvés dans dans des livres
il était dit que
au moyen âge pendant les jours de carême
ont mangé donc pas de viande mais la
consommation de de caster était
autorisée du fait que l'on croyait que
c'était un poisson et quel est le lien
entre le castor et le sol c'est qu'ils
ont le prescrivait également en cas de
migraine tout simplement pourquoi parce
que le castor en rongeant en partie du
sol qui est un arbre qui pousse en bord
de zones humides contient une molécule
celle qui est contenu par exemple dans
l'aspirine d'accord voilà donc on peut
consommer du sol sur la tête non non
gratae le camp mais alors la venue est
venu l'essai ça vaut mieux laisser ça
aux médecins mais voilà sur le principe
il ya encore une deuxième anecdote sont
le être l'être
bon on connaît tous la farine on connaît
tous une fine un peu plus original qui
est celle de la châtaigne en période de
disette au moyen âge on faisait
également une farine à partir du fruit
fait par lettre la scène donc c'était
une farine certes de deux maigres
qualité mais on parlait de disette on
serait porté là dessus par exemple on a
plein de choses à découvrir donc ses
ballades puncheuse d'accord donc en tout
cas pour l'été ces balades du 10 juillet
au 7 août c'est gratuit oui rendez vous
13 heures 45 à l'office de tourisme
merci sine die
allez dernière balade que je vous
propose ou plutôt évidemment que
christophe vous propose alors cette
balade à l'est elle est vraiment adapté
pour toutes les familles elle part de la
ferme du manet à montigny le bretonneux
elle vous propose un circuit historique
autour du site de port royal des champs
à magny les hameaux site où je me trouve
actuellement c'est vraiment une balade
bucolique chargé d'histoire ya pas
beaucoup de difficultés en gros c'est
idéal pour les enfants alors je vous
propose une balade maintenant avant real
deschamps on se situe là dans la cour de
la ferme du manet dont les bâtiments
datent du 16e siècle donc c'est une
balade qui fait environ une douzaine de
kilomètres donc tu peux rester à allure
normale en une heure et pour les
sportifs
une petite demi-heure syfia allez vous
me suivez
la grosse particularité de cette boîte
donc c'est de découvrir
principalement donc la ferme du manet
donc oui on vous fait passer par
quelques chemins et bien sûr on peut on
peut sortir 2
entier s'aventurer
il ya deux choses principales à
découvrir lors de ce bal il ya bien sûr
le site de port réal deschamps
sur le site de port royal des champs
donc il ya plusieurs choses assez sympa
allez découvrir donc il ya le musée
national il y a le verger les jardins
historiques et aussi les ruines de
l'abbaye qui sont peut être sympa à
visiter
c'est une ballade principalement à
travers forêts ya pas de difficultés
particulières lors de cette balade donc
c'est vraiment une battre réservé pour
tout le monde
pour les familles comme pour les
sportifs qui peu après et tendres et
tendres le parcours
mon coup de coeur stade balade c'est
sur l'abbaye de port royal donc et
derrière il ya un parc dans lequel on
peut s'installer et pique-niqué sur
lequel on en fait on voit toute la
vallée de chevreuse et ça reste un site
assez sympa à découvrir
voilà j'espère en tout cas que ça vous
aura vraiment donné envie soit prendre
le btt soit de chaussez vos rollers ou
encore vos chaussures de marche vous
avez vu un serment des balades
accessibles à tout le monde et a
retrouvé bien entendu sur le site
internet de l'office de tourisme moi je
vous souhaite un excellent tt soyez
curieux et sportif et toujours avec le
sourire
bonjour je m'appelle fait aujourd'hui ce
groupe
et je vais vous présenter à bâle
ok c'est pas les
voleurs
ont fait le cac ou devant la télé un
incident architectes ont travaillé au
lit
donc c'est vraiment la vraie balade pour
les familles